[Musique]
et on commence avec ce geste qui a
permis sans doute de sauver la vie de
nombreuses personnes celui donc de la
personne qui a maîtrisé l'auteur de
l'attaque au couteau samedi à la gare de
Lyon il s'agit d'un agent de sécurité
embauché par une entreprise ivelinoise
oui grégoryi celui qui a réussi à
neutraliser et désarmer la saillance et
lui abdahman 6c cet agent de sécurité de
45 ans est employé par la société ESP
sécurité basée à mon le bretonux expert
en sport de combat et vigile depuis 20
ans il fait partie des task forces
mobilisées dans les grandes gares du
pays l'agent de sécurité est aujourd'hui
rentrée chez lui après un court passage
à l'hôpital suite à cette attaque trois
personnes ont été blessées dont une
gravement laassaillant quant à lui a été
interpellé puis placé en garde à vue ce
dimanche j'en parlais dans les titres
après plusieurs mois d'incertitude on en
sait plus sur la gestion de l'île de
loisirs de 50 ans en Yveline c'est exact
Grégory Valérie pcrè la présidente de la
région île-defance annon auprès de nos
confrères du Parisien en reprendre la
gestion au total 4 millions d'euros
seront investis chaque année par la
région pour assurer le fonctionnement de
l'île des loisirs pour rappel jusqu'en
décembre 2023 la région Île-de-France
était simplement chargée des
investissements de la base tandis que le
département et l'agglomération de 50 ans
en libline se partager les frais de
fonctionnement les deux collectivités se
sont retirées du Syndicat de Gestion de
la base dans l'interview accordé aux
Parisiens la présidente de la région n'a
pas hésité à pointer du doigt le
département
et donc je cite Valérie pcrè voilà en
arrêtant de financer l'île le
département a tourné le dos à la
vocation sociale supposée être la sienne
quand on joue en équipe on est solidaire
et on ne marque pas contre son camp
l'équipe de direction a été incapable de
gérer correctement cette île alors que
la région elle a investi plus de 6
millions d'euros depuis 2016 voici les
mots rapportés par Le Parisien de Valéri
PCR et du côté du département des iines
selon nos informations aucune réaction à
chaud ne sera faite par rapport à la
mise en cause de la présidente du
conseil régional d'île-de-fance
l'entourage de Pierre Bédier nous fait
savoir que la position du département
est totalement assumée il précise que
l'institution départementale est
favorable au maintien de l'activité de
l'île de loisir de cquentin niivline
alors justement toujours concernant
Valérie pcret ce lundi matin le maire de
guyan courours François Morton tenait
une conférence de presse pour alerter
sur les mesures antig-etto voulues par
la présidente de région tout à fait
Grégory pour appel en mars 2022 la
région Île-de-France a lancé la révision
de son schéma directeur environnemental
pour décider de l'aménagement du
territoire d'ici à 2040 en septembre
2023 la présidente de la région Valérie
pcrè décidé d'y inclure une clause
antig-hetto visant à freiner la
production de logements sociaux dans les
communes en don en comptant au moins 30
% l'objectif est selon elle de freiner
jeite le communautarisme et l'islamisme
une apération pour François Morton dont
la commune directement concernée compte
50 % de logements sociaux on écoute sa
réaction au micro de Julien lurois
l'application de cette clause antig-etto
aurait comme effet immédiat
une baisse de production de logements
sociaux de 21 % et donc elle nous
interdirait à terme de continuer à
construire du logement social là où 7 %
des franiliens ils sont éligibles qu'on
nous fasse confiance nous connaissons
nos villes nous savons effectivement
comment les les peupler comment apporter
le service public qui va avec malgré les
baisses drastiques de dotation moi je
crois qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur voilà
il faut permettre à chacun de pouvoir se
loger dignement on termine avec une
information sp sportif 5 mois avant le
début des Jeux Olympiques le Stadium de
BMX reace on le rappelle situé juste à
côté du Vélodrome national de 50 ans en
Iline va être remodelé l'objectif à
respecter l'équité avec les futures
nations et ne pas avantager la nation
haute lors des épreuves car vous le
savez l'équipe de France utilise
quotidiennement cette piste alors
pendant 4 semaines les équipes de la
solidéo la société de livraison des
ouvrages olympiques vont réaménager la
piste spécialement pour les jeux sa
longueur restera la même mais deux
tribunes temporair seront aménager pour
accueillir jusqu'à 3000 spectateurs les
tests opérationnels sont prévus du 5 au
7 avril 2024 merci Michel et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoins d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les Yvelines
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
78 news